alors le tournoi mégantic cette fois je
m'adresse à un jeune homme qui s'appelle
adrien aubert qui vit à lac mégantic et
qui a filmé les toutes premières minutes
de l' incendie qui a suivi l'accident du
train dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
il est devant la polyvalente montignac à
lac-mégantic bonjour rien
les minimales bonjour merci beaucoup
alors là on va regarder un peu les
images que vous allez ça ça ses toutes
premières images que vous avez tourné on
est on vous écoute en même temps parce
que vous parler au téléphone
votre copine sans doute qui s'appelle
karine on écoute un peu
tout le centre ville 100 m en feu
centre-ville au grand complet
akin m
dieu oh là là je m'éloignais là
voilà
alors bonjour adrien aubin
dites moi vous étiez vous étiez akouala
200 mètres peut-être pas plus ans de
chansons table oui tout à fait mais
arrivés entre le oui allez-y racontez
nous un peu comment comment vous avez
vécu ça et à partir de quel moment là
mais dans le fond ce soir là on jouait
au théâtre à l'église de marston est
d'habitude après nos pièces de théâtre
on va boire une bière ou du café à
l'auberge
puis cette fois ci on avait décidé de
s'arrêter par chez moi cinq minutes de
musique a fait pour pour aller prendre
un verre
est ce à ce moment là que que de chez de
chez moi j'ai j'ai pu voir par la
fenêtre que d'un coup il s'est mis à
faire jour j'ai pas de suite compris de
quoi il s'agissait
au début à la mi avec qui j'étais on
pensait que c'était peut-être des feux
d'artifice mais ça valait vraiment trop
gros pour être ça donc on est sortis en
vitesse j'ai eu le réflexe de prendre la
caméra et puis quand on est arrivés sur
place
c'était juste quelque chose qu'on
pouvait pas vous pouvez vraiment pas
imaginer on pourrait imaginer qu'un
incendie mais de cette ampleur là ça a
été ça a été vraiment quand vous pouvez
voir les images
c'était apocalyptique comme on peut
l'entendre beaucoup ces temps ci les
images sont absolument impressionnante
et tout au long vous parlez avec karine
vous échangez avec karine c'est sans
doute une amie oui tout à fait c'est
cela ma conjointe et là quelle explosion
celle là et maintenant vous dites à
regarder ça la met sentiez-vous la
justice nous sentirons en danger ah ben
c'est sûr que
je m'attendais pas à une telle explosion
et puis après on a plusieurs autres qui
ont suivi on sent la chaleur ont surtout
aussi la lumière qui qui en dégagent aux
voix tout comme en plein jour
l'espace de quelques secondes donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on a rarement
l'occasion de voir dans ces avis donc
c'est vrai c'est assez impressionnant
attendons si j'ai bien compris vous
n'êtes pas allé aux musiques à fait vous
aviez l'intention d'y aller mais vous
n'êtes pas allé aux musiques à fait oui
tout à fait on n'est pas allé non ben
sinon je pense que j'aurais peut-être
pas la chance de pouvoir être là et
témoigner de ça aujourd'hui
est-ce que les gens se rendaient compte
est ce que vous vous rendiez compte de
l'ampleur de la chose les gens chantent
tétine de chez eux
fuyez t-il de l'endroit mais c'est sûr
que c'est sûr qu'il ya du monde qui
était encore chez eux en train de dormir
ceux qui étaient dans la rue c'était un
mélange y avait de la panique mais il y
avait aussi beaucoup de monde qui resté
bouche bée
pas vraiment avoir de réaction je pense
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
s'attend pas à voir surtout surtout dans
ce coin du globe et surtout dans ce coin
du québec donc c'est quelque chose que
je pense ça on ne peut pas se préparer
et piron
je pense que physiquement on n'est pas
capable de vraiment réagir à ce genre de
ce genre d'ampleur d'explosions et de
d'ascendis avez vous des amis qui
étaient aux musiques affluent
malheureusement oui je pense comme
beaucoup de monde ici c'est un c'est une
ville où tout le monde se connaît ou
donc oui je pense comme tout le monde
malheureusement on a du monde qui sont
encore portés disparus qui ont ces
mesures ont quand même est-ce que les
gens quand même pu fuir ce que j'ai pris
comprendre c'est que ceux qui étaient
sur la terrasse donc du côté de la rue
avait eu plus de chance de s'en sortir
et de fuir puisque ce qui se fait dans
le café mais oui c'est ça ben j'ai pu
parler à des amis qui étaient
effectivement sur la terrasse et des
gens qui ont à peine eu le temps de voir
le train passer par réflexe son parti
aussi vite qu'ils pouvaient
malheureusement tout ce qui était
derrière eux ont pas eu cette même
chance tous ceux qui étaient à
l'intérieur
je pense qu'ils ont ils ont ils n'ont
pas pu prendre le temps de savoir ce qui
se passe est que en tout cas c'est ça a
été assez rapidement pour les gens au
café et puis pour les gens aussi autour
est-ce que vous avez des amis qui sont
décédés des amis dont vous êtes certain
qu'ils sont décédés écoutez selon la
version officielle il ya toujours rien
de confirmé mais c'est sûr que c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui trois jours après les
personnes qui sont portées disparues on
a l'espoir est de plus en plus mince
mais même quand on voit les photos et
les images on peut pas vraiment imaginer
que que du monde qui était en tout cas
en musique à fait confirmé au musical
paix et puis s'en sortir donc oui
malheureusement on a des amis qui sont
qui ont été confirmés
merci pour ce qu'a confirmé simple par
la version officielle vous dire une
chose c'est que oui c'est que lac
mégantic
c'est une ville avec des gens vraiment
extraordinaire et tout ce qui touche au
centre ville c'était des entrepreneurs
avec une véritable vision et je voulais
juste passer un message de soutien et de
dire que à tout le québec que ma cliente
va se relever de ses cendres et que si
vous voulez aider aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de l'argent qu'il faut envoyer
à la croix rouge donc je vous remercie
et puis et puis encore tout mon soutien
à toute la région de mégantic et à tous
ceux qui sont touchés de près ou de loin
merci beaucoup adrien aubin remercie
infiniment d'avoir pu le temps de parler